ever wonder what me being born looks
like don't tell me you didn't see
vaginas in this headboard I think I hit
a setting and now this is a different
frame speed I don't know how to change
it guys please deal with it thank you
Wow look at this frame art half hello my
name is grace Helbig welcome to Friday
arre if you did not know fried Diaries I
look back on my week in vlog form I have
been on the UK leg of the Grayson style
book tour and here to look back at how
that has been going for me and you guys
hi London I am inside of you so if
you've ever wondered what my dirty talk
sounds like keep on wondering I'm in my
hotel in London and I didn't just get
here no I think I arrived almost 24
hours ago but I slept for 16 of them I
ordered room service then fell asleep
immediately and then continued to sleep
and wake up eating bits of room service
and chocolate for 16 hours which as we
all know is a classic London tradition
or maybe it's just a classic grace
helbig travel tradition sleeping and
then waking up and eating and then going
back to sleep and then waking up and
continuing to eat it's becoming a
frequent thing for me and I don't know
if it's good but I'm forced to become a
human and not a sloppy sloth like
individual because I have to go to some
meetings say going to a meeting which is
in walking distance very exciting and
then hoping that I have some time before
my second meeting which is actually a
phone call to go shopping I also feel
slightly under the weather more sex talk
okay
so I'm trying to take it easy and come
back and just sleep what like I spent
time doing this to my hair for some
reason what is happening give me all
your brand deals look this is what
London looks like I'm gonna show you a
sign that I thought was just me looking
into a mirror for a long time before I
realized it was a sign
hey outfit of the day travel outfit why
not this hats from Topshop this shirt is
from Zara I have one in white and one in
this tan color I wish they made them in
every color possible this jacket it's
Topshop found in a closet
these high-waisted jeans are Topshop and
these boots are H&M my favorite travel
boots also travel essential um it's safe
to say that I am obsessed with the
Elizabeth and James Nirvana black calves
it in a dry shampoo in a hand lotion and
in a roll-on perfume this is the best
don't let anyone peer pressure you into
any other sense unless they come with
free gifts hello it is day is this
considered day two in London I guess
it's take two in London I had some
meetings today I went on that I told you
about earlier that I didn't show you
anything else which was just shopping so
I thought I was sitting here watching s
de la lune is a lovely style vlogger
lifestyle person cool inspiring human
human Pinterest board basically I was
watching one for home videos and I
thought oh why don't I just do a haul
and show you guys what I bought because
you know internet also I have very low
expectations for myself filming enough
content this week to feel like this vlog
was really all-encompassing so I'm gonna
shoot a bunch of shoot no.2 flat whites
hanging out okay let's get into it where
did I go to hell and back
okay Topshop it was a lot of a lot I
meant to lovely gentleman in there that
watch my videos hello to both of you
whose names I forget
Liam maybe it's one of you maybe there
was a Daniel Jeffery Tom Charles
chinchilla
it sounds like a British boys name d do
you think why not I can do it everyone
on this channel these are just ballet
flats from Topshop that I love they're
26 American dollars they're just a nude
Sonya managed
flatten it nude ballerinas up in here I
love these very much they go with a lot
of things they're really great for when
you want your foot to look like your
foot but not showcase the grossest of
your foot like a Barbie's crotch it
smooths over so you don't see like the
grossest that is an actual vagina these
like Barbie crotch your feet for you
yeah yeah yeah this is a hummingbird
necklace I saw this when I walked in to
Topshop and I bought it because I like
it and hummingbird
it's like me try so hard that you look
at them and think they might explode I
feel you yeah yeah I got a jean jacket I
had one while ago and then I got rid of
it because I didn't like it anymore and
then I saw a bunch of people coming to
different signings wearing denim jackets
and I liked them so much that I got one
for myself
and there's that plus I was reminiscing
the other day about the television show
hey dude and it was a great series on
Nickelodeon and the cinema jock it just
makes me think about it yeah you say yes
a Hoff this is a flouncy top it's
basically a shirt made of fabric that
makes you want to go found you get it
ooh very Mad Men secretary Meets The
Crucible yeah yes yeah yes and this is a
sweatshirt the Tigers of Versailles and
this color is maybe the most confusing
color I've ever seen in my life it looks
a little bit purple a little bit grey a
little bit pink Brown it looks like
vomit or diarrhea but you don't know
which one and the mystery is what makes
it chic which is Aurra
so fun that I just go to all the stores
that I go to in the states when I'm here
yeah yeah after this I am absolutely in
love with forest-green graphic tile
motif II shaped clutch with a gold
pineapple top I mean Shmi in the ass and
call it Wednesday this is great it was
23 pounds and I has a shop if you need
to pour it you need a shoulder for it to
cry on I love it very much
I just talked you up so much and you
just went straight into my ankle one
dummy bunny of that was the sound of it
hitting my vagina and that's how you
found out that I had a metal vagina have
some water tarnish from boots but I'm
not really going to show you guys that
maybe I'll show you that in a favorites
video later on this month if they become
my favorites I don't know we'll have to
find out hey hey is my vagina metal I
don't know have to find out on a future
episode of an its greatest YouTube video
let's move on with whatever's happening
the rest of the way because this
battery's about to die
okay we're backstage back bookstore at
our first UK signing in Liverpool
the excitement is through the roof and
then later today we go to Manchester
yeah later cheb go to Manchester are you
slowly moving out afraid
yeah that sound day and dances don't
take day in line dancing it's take hours
everyone gets ready for the Manchester
signing yeah yeah yeah we do a bonding
exercise
yeah we just do tiny trust Falls
kübra but hey guys it is the end of the
first day of the official UK Grace's
town book tour we went to tired down
that's where my brain just went right
now
Oh God Liverpool we went to Liverpool
this morning and then we went to
Manchester this afternoon and we're
currently in Manchester and then going
to Leeds in the morning and then to
Nottingham tomorrow night and it was
just a really great day of meeting
really wonderful people people that gave
me all of this nonsense so much candy so
many beautiful letters and drawings that
are so well done it's just insane I'm
actually I'm having a can do dinner
because I'm an adult and no one can tell
me otherwise pretty cool
up here is my um array of taste-tested
candies all delicious I tried this one
I've never had before lion
guess what delicious fudge delicious
Cadbury mini eggs guess what she
delicious some of you might be like hey
do a American tries British candies nope
this is what it would look like
delicious that's delicious also
delicious
hey this is delicious people to try
candy and they do not like it you in
your butthole candies delicious thank
you to the girl that got me a emergency
dental care so you guys are extremely
talented artists this is much more
attractive than my actual face good job
maybe I look like a real doll I'm so
tired but I am mmm I'm really tired but
not like fall asleep tire like my brain
still kind of fizzling so I just want to
give you update on today really
wonderful first day Thank You UK you are
okay oh and I got a french fry pillow
like this is art I get art I love you
are at New York Fashion Week this week
this is my Fashion Week I'm so bummed
right now you guys i was importing all
these clips of all the stuff shot over
the week for a diary and i had to make
space on my computer to import clips and
in doing so i accidentally deleted like
ten clips from this week and i
I've been drying Vlasic to enough hours
to get them back I cannot find them
anywhere I'm so bummed its footage from
like for book signings that I don't have
like Leeds Nottingham Milton Keynes and
Cardiff which is such a huge bummer
however reward to those that were
following me on snapchat that's where I
post most of the daily stuff of the book
signings and biggest rewards to those
actually came to those book signings
experience them in real life putting
this clip in now let you know here is
where that footage would have gone
spoiler alert they were all amazing book
signings with incredibly nice humans in
attendance I'm so pissed I don't have
this footage sorry you guys take me
seriously it's safe to say that Cardiff
signing went very well today I think
this is something Welsh I hope it's a
positive sign up this is not some sort
of offensive Welsh gang clothing myth
haha yes the signings in Cardiff Oh went
so well so thank you for everyone that
showed up Morrow is our very last
signing of the whole Grace and style
book tour
unless magically they're our signings
added on there aren't right now it
hasn't hit me that it's happened or that
it's just coming to an end but I want to
say very very huge huge tremendous thank
you to everyone that showed up an event
every single event was so lovely and
every person that worked the event that
worked at the bookstore commented to me
on how wonderful all of you were that
showed up and I felt weirdly proud
because if I like you guys were a
reflection of me and so it was cool to
see cool people there so thank you guys
for being good humans this is the face I
make when I'm confused by my own
feelings of Pride and continue to send
me your photos with the books and things
you like you didn't like about it
because I love hearing what you think
about it now it's Friday in London and
I'm gonna stay in and edit and read some
letters from you guys probably put the
line onesie back on because TGIF I'm G
gif al boo boo Chiti
pretty much speaks for itself well maybe
I'll make a t-shirt tonight oh here's
something that I didn't get to show you
guys one I spilled soy sauce on the bed
where is it up there it is travel
essentials for you guys for the for tour
heart gave me um her little apothecary
of essential oils that she used on her
book tour to prevent sickness and I've
been using two of them like crazy that I
wanted to mention to you guys maybe
it'll help you maybe this is nonsense
information for you oil of oregano there
haha yes
oil of oregano this stuff is amazing it
does not taste that good it tastes like
oregano that makes you feel like you ate
a pizza but not in like a good way just
in like the flavor of it is stuck in
your mouth kinda way and you put like
four or five drops I put it in water
some people can put it directly in their
mouth and then I drink that like two or
three times a day and I really think
it's prevented me from getting like
full-blown sick on this tour I do that
and then I do holy basil leaf yeah look
at that like 10 or so drops of this in
water you can do a little bit more it's
not as strong as the oregano and it has
really I also think helped prevent my
illness so thank you memory heart for
being just a medical rescue for me over
this tour so that's really important
this is a very aggressive background to
be walking in front of I'm sorry this is
hard to look at is it not here's where
it sets in that it's almost end of tour
maybe I feel a little crazy but what
else can I show you tour essentials tour
toiletries that are essentials oh I put
you on a tripod because that's how
serious I am right now these are almost
like favorites in a way but not
favorites I'll do another favorites
video John Frieda's root touch-up powder
it's powder that looks like this it's
kind of gross it looks like makeup it's
like long obviously for my roots and it
comes with this little brush and watch
you just kind of tap this on and then
you put it on the root
aha okay now look at that
before-and-after Wow this uh huh this is
first date beauties detox eye roller and
I do this in the morning I think I've
shown this in a video before maybe it's
got this metal Rolly ball on the top and
you roll under your eyes and it's
supposed to deep puff the under-eye area
from lack of sleep I think it works it
stings a little bit and that's how I
think it's working
beauty's pain maybe is it okay I think
that's it okay there's some of my tour
essentials that I've really been loving
that are just good for life in general
to not Victoria because that's a really
nice thing to associate this with let's
gonna have this clip okay we're gonna
wrap up Friday right now tomorrow is the
very last book signing at Bluewater if
you are coming I'm so excited to see you
I hope if you're on the fence about it
you decide to come because it's the last
one of the Grayson style book tour and I
can't even begin to put into where it's
how wonderful this has been thank you is
really the only thing I can continue to
say and I will continue to say it thank
you very much all of you for support and
just for being nice maybe I'll get into
this in another video in the future but
I've been having a lot of thoughts
lately about kindness which is very cool
also I've been having a lot of thoughts
I'm just going to float this by you guys
no one freaked out everyone think this
through with me I've been having some
thoughts about not doing Friday anymore
because I love snapchat so much and I
have a really hard time balancing using
snapchat I wanting to use it with using
friary
thinking of getting rid of Freud I re
doing more snapchat and then commenting
on comments on Fridays what do you think
of that I could be really fun right we
get some not too deep on Monday some
thin random on Wednesday and then
commenting on comments on Friday let me
know what you think leave a comment down
below I would love to hear your feedback
I actually need your feedback to make
this decision so help me
what am i becoming and don't forget to
subscribe if you haven't already because
god damnit I really want to pass three
million subscribers I'm just going to
say it I'm putting it out there as
positive thoughts I'm doing a lily sing
right now I'm putting a thought out
there I really want to pass three
million subscribers it's out there now
into the universe shoot up universe I
mean like in a good way make it happen
and that's it okay we'll see you guys at
some point I'm sure I don't know I
spilled soy sauce from sushi that I
bought yesterday and I had like a few
minutes of debating whether I should eat
the sushi I decided to eat the sushi cuz
it didn't smell weird it's not a little
weird but I ate it because I'm not going
anywhere tonight so you can go crazy all
you want stomach it's just you with me
in this hotel bathroom tonight and then
I spilled the soy sauce from it on the
bed while wearing this sweatshirt very
own brand in the privacy of my own hotel
room
good job self